let's show to the story from ABC News
Kansas must stop changing trans people's
sex listing on driver's licenses judge
says a state court a court judge has
ordered Kansas to stop allowing trans
people to change the listing for sex on
their driver's license this one caused a
lot of contentious issues there on the
internet as many people on the left are
saying it's far-right fascism Etc et
cetera but uh my question with this
story is actually quite simple the
reason why I want to bring it up in this
conversation
if the left continually says sex and
gender are different
why would a trans person ever change
their sex on a birth certificate or
driver's license when they are not in
fact changing their sex they are just
conf they're trying to con affirm or
confirm their gender which is a social
construct yeah well right this is how it
started they created this nonsensical
distinction between sex and gender
gender is a term that was only used to
describe language so they took something
that only referred to inanimate objects
or or I shouldn't even call it an object
but an artifact of language and they
applied it to humans which already has
dehumanizing connotations to it
hold on they didn't do that we did it
because of what words naturally acquired
meaning
coined the term gender identity and then
on government documents It'll ask you
your gender not your sex yes so it's not
referring to the the to the male or
female nature of a word it eventually
came to mean biological sex exactly so
what happened was because people were
uncomfortable saying Saxon wanted a
euphemism they would just say gender
instead so some instances it was used
interchangeably and then sometimes it
was used to say well your sex and gender
identity are two different things
because your sex is the biological
reality and your gender is the
expression and they said that for a very
long time to get people to accept
transgenderism but now they've pushed
the two back together and what do they
say oh actually your gender is also your
biological sex because if you say this
is what you are we have to also say that
that's what your biological sex is so
the issue here is there's a reason why
we ask for the sex of the individual
typically for medical reasons
I mean that that's basically it
we can see the picture of your face on
the card if we want to know it's you
we'll look at the picture on your face
the reason sex is listed is literally in
case someone needs to identify your bio
your biology and they can't tell some
people are naturally feminine looking
and some women are naturally masculine
looking their instances where people are
androgynous and so let's say you have a
heart attack and you collapse medical
person is going to come in do they have
an ID on them they're gonna look at your
ID and be like okay they're female okay
we know
a bit about their body it's going to be
different from a male body changing it
does nothing to inform anyone of
anything quite the opposite actually so
if the real issue is they want to affirm
their gender and they believe gender and
sex are different things to the point
where there are non-binary people simply
because they don't want to wear a suit
or a dress then why would you ever
change sex on a on a government document
yeah well because you constantly need
the constructions of your own mind to be
validated and you constantly need a
grieving so you're just going to keep
pushing it down the line saying like
well you've accepted my gender identity
but you don't accept my sex I mean it's
all nonsense but you're absolutely right
you need to know a person's sex
medically especially if they're
unconscious and they can't communicate
it to you like you described different
medicines might be able to be used in a
specific situation but not another one
like depending on your sex it's also
true of dosages of medicines well so
this is this is the the print one of the
principal identifiers of it being a cult
the left adheres to things that make no
sense for no reason other than you must
that's it the larger group agrees on a
concept and you must fall in line with
whatever the majority of that cult
believes and does even if it serves no
purpose or makes no sense if you
disagree in fact this is actually
probably the principal component of the
cult the ultimate test will you agree to
something that is not true yes or no
and so as you can see many of these
people will come out and say
gender and sex are different you'll say
okay they'll say also a person can
change their sex you're like hold on
hold on
if a non- if a person is gender fluid
their gender can change and if a person
wants to get gender confirmation surgery
they are confirming their gender not
their sex you are now conflating sex and
gender as a single thing while
simultaneously arguing and oh oh you've
challenged us
exposing yourself
I think to a great degree the point of
of holding contradictory claims is so
that people who aren't falling in line
with the cult expose themselves exactly
do you what do you feel about this do
you think this is a horrible bigoted
thing I think it's ridiculous I mean
it's all about their affirmation you
know and they need to you know everyone
needs to confirm what they are but it's
definitely two different things and
medically I mean it's important to know
when when somebody arrives in the
emergency room and there's you know a
problem there's different
you know ways to go about approaching
the patient so yeah I mean I think
different medications yeah or or even
like CPR I think is a little bit
different or you know there's all kinds
of different things but this is just
it's it's right you're right it's a cult
and it's either you you know go in
lockstep with what they say
or you're bummed out which is why I
think the lady you had on earlier that's
great that she finally you know but they
only took one thing it only took one
thing for her to go against and then
well apparently it's been a year it's
been a couple years I just finally like
okay I can't do this anymore right I
wonder how far off we are from them just
removing the sex category from a
driver's license and having you put your
pronouns there and that's it that's all
we need to know pronouns are also
another thing it's all meant to identify
you as a part of the cult that that
that's really that's really it I think
it's all I I think it also adds to that
element of there being a humiliation
requirement or humiliation ritual I mean
before this ideology infested everything
the idea that you would ask someone
whether you should call them he or she
would be and should be considered
incredibly insulting right what are you
talking about well hold on you can't
tell I I I would welcome anybody there's
a meme going around where it's like I
tried the the the the lizzo test that's
what they called it oh no oh and they
like my and and my uh my aunt started
crying they they basically said he said
he went up to his aunt and said in in a
polite way you look like a trans woman
and he said his aunt started crying
that's mean and he was like but she was
very liberal and very pro-trans and was
arguing and saying all the stuff and
then he said something like well you
know you look like a trans woman and
then she got really angry and started
crying and his point was like why are
you crying if you like and respect trans
women and you think they're good and
beautiful why would you cry if someone
called you that because they're lying
yeah they're in a cult she knew he
wasn't calling her brave right yeah yeah
that's not what that implies
yep
so I'm kind of thinking about this like
in the future I'm not going to ask
someone if they if where they are
politically I'm going to say are you are
you in the cult or or not in the cult
and then just see what they say because
I've had like liberal family members be
like you're saying that I'm going to
close I disagree with you and I'm like
no I'm saying you're an occult because
you believe things that are
contradictory and you're too afraid to
say anything against the contradictions
because people will attack you and you
fear that yeah see other people will be
like that quite doesn't make sense
whether or not they get attacked one is
free knowing uh freedom is dangerous and
the others are scared into saying things
that don't make sense and contradict
themselves like two plus two equals five
out of fear of what might happen to them
socially one's occult one's not yeah no
exactly I mean we in all of us disagree
on certain things I don't think we've
ever really like accused each other of
being cult numbers on the basis of those
disagreements so the idea that we're
just gonna claim anyone who's outside of
our values is a cult member is
ridiculous it's not about that like this
is a particularly strange set of values
that have incredibly strict standards uh
not even a set of values dude well we
values is a term that can just refer to
what somebody like literally values and
the things they value are very bizarre
when we had a particular leftist on this
show
we're talking about these books these
shockingly uh gratuitous books in
schools yeah and she goes so you're in
favor of abstinence only sex ed and I
was like No And she was oh I'm like
because you're an occult right you can't
you can't you can't uh comprehend
contradictions you it's it's all just
anything the left says must be true no
matter what and anyone who disagrees
must be the other with me or against me
that's right but look at who you I mean
it is worth taking into consideration
who you were dealing with and and the
point of them being but that's most of
these people well they're they're not
they're look there are intelligent
political commentators hey surprise
surprise they tend to fall in a similar
set of beliefs we can talk about uh
Destiny a liberal guy but he has no
issue coming here and and having a
discussion because he actually believes
things and it's like a real conversation
about them yeah then you have cult
members who will say literally anything
so long as it fits the cult narrative
right it's not about politics yeah like
Destiny would look in the information
he'd he'd change his opinion he's is not
going to like totally be disingenuous
he'll look at something CC facts and C
numbers be like oh okay you're right
about that where's my other people would
look at the numbers we're just
completely look Beyond them just so so
when you mentioned the people we're
talking to there's a reason why when we
have Destiny on and have this
conversation it's not generating
millions of millions of clips and
millions of views and when we have a
cult number on it does yeah because
Destiny's not a cult member exactly and
so people are not he's he's he may as
well be considered right-wing them at
this point well seriously no your
political positions do not determine
whether or not you are left or right
anymore yeah I mean is as long as you
anger that group to some extent they're
going to label you far right not just
right wing but like far right and
fashion if you say that Joe Biden there
is evidence that he engaged in corrupt
activities insert whichever one you are
now conservative if you make a movie
criticizing child trafficking they call
it a conservative movie yes they call it
faith-based religious it's sound of
Freedom was just a movie they call it
they call it on father and it's pro-q
and on and it's uh what else do they say
about it that it's it's for dads with
brain worms or something I think that
was the Rolling Stone review that was
published I mean I wonder why people
connected to Hollywood are so concerned
about a movie that sheds Awareness on
child trafficking becoming popular this
is the point there's nothing political
in the movie nothing no not really it's
a law enforcement agent tracking down
criminals and saving kids but you know
what else and here's the thing you're
correct that that's not political but to
them it is not only for some of the more
nefarious reasons we could point to but
just portraying law enforcement in a
positive light is already a massive
issue for them it does speak to the fact
that the the left
does politicize everything and and
they're going to be people that or there
would be people that would push back on
that and say well Phil you know the
right does it too or or whatever but if
you look at the philosophy of the of the
left and the thinkers on the left the
idea of the personal is political came
from the left like that that's what the
the early feminists were saying I think
it was the feminist that first started
saying the personal is political and
it's something that expands to to other
uh types of leftism or other genres of
leftism or whatever the the LGBT issues
that we see right now are because they
demand sexuality to be a political topic
it doesn't have to be it could be simply
look you don't teach children you know
sex ed
possibly at all because you know human
beings have figured it out for
couple hundred thousand years that human
beings have been human before we had you
know government schools so it's not like
it's necessary to ensure the survival of
the population the for the government to
explain how sex works that's not
necessarily necessary at all but the
reason to have these things in school is
because they can be made political if
you can cast something in a political
light and make young people start asking
political questions when they're you
know 10 11 12. then you can make
activists out of them and that's the
goal the intent is to make activists out
of kids so whether it be LGBT issues or
whatever the the dynamic is whether it
be race issues or whatever anytime you
can get young people activated
politically you're going to get a a
portion of them that are going to become
committed political actors and they're
going to become the activists of of you
know the Next Generation and stuff and
so the point is to politicize as much as
possible from the left with leftist
talking points or with leftist
perspectives that's why you have your
average mom and dad that are like hold
on we want we don't want our kids to
learn this stuff and the government's
you know sending the FBI after you know
because that's literally what happens
I'm not I've made up one thing all of
that stuff is factual things that have
happened so again I'll get pushback from
some of the people that are that are
friends of mine that are on that are
left leaning and it's like look I'm not
making any of this up this is just
talking about things that are happening
and have have happened so and I think so
the idea that the person was political
is something that that lives on the left
yeah no I mean I I would agree with a
lot of that I would say that and I don't
think you would actually disagree that
there are some in in probably many
massive goals with showing this stuff to
kids that go beyond just a mere
political statement yes but I I will
those are opportunists I think I think
those are those are I think it's I think
it's a mixture I think they're they're
opportunist but I think there actually
are people who want to uphold like a
kind of systemic grooming and I'll also
add here that the reason we have sex out
of any form firstly I don't think it's
going to shock anyone to hear me say I
think this is something that parents
should be doing and not schools but the
whole reason we have these programs is
to tell people what not to do people are
going to figure out what they can do
with their bodies all right you have to
tell them what they're not supposed to
do so to show them a bunch of perverted
stuff that they hadn't considered is not
sex ad that that is grooming the purpose
of sex that is boundaries don't do this
thing don't do this till you're married
even like the more comprehensive
programs by the way which I don't agree
with that terminology I don't agree with
teaching kids about birth control but
even they'll say don't do this without
birth control like the whole point is
supposed to be about saying don't do
this thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored Members Only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time